well that's a crap negotiation basically
I can lead nowhere now but I mean at the
very point just to bring it more he's
supposedly made a deal with the
Palestinians who run the West Bank you
know what happens to win Hamas here said
well we don't accept it that's a big
problem for everybody so afraid your
negotiation one of the things your
negotiations got to do is create a
situation which you overcome that so
that they do a part to enforce it
because be quite clear about this unless
each side is sure the other can enforce
the deal they're not going to make the
deal because then they're giving
something up and they're not getting in
return that of course is the Israeli
issue in a way now what we're trying to
do is to create a Palestinian Authority
that is strong enough and a process that
has got enough momentum behind it so
that then they say people in Gaza do you
want to be part of this or not and a
mask then I've got a choice they either
get behind it or they stay outside it
right but the short answer is you have
to resolve that because otherwise you
don't have a deal you know so the thing
in Northern Ireland is where we and this
is one major major difference with the
Middle East situation in Northern
Ireland I mean I've never come across a
more disciplined political party than
shin pain right so there was no question
at all I mean the IRS methods of
enforcing party discipline were slightly
unusual let's say I'm not saying as a
party leader I didn't have some sympathy
with it but it's but if you did a deal
with them I mean the one thing that
wasn't an issue is that if they signed
they could deliver right and to be fair
to them they never said look they're
like me what they said is to deliver we
need to bring our people with us but
there was no question if they said okay
we brought them with us we're here they
would enforce that this is this is the
problem in the Middle East peace process
but there is a way rounded however you
have to find a real one you can't leave
that unresolved